[Music]
you're doing on your talk-show Kathy
this is where you're actually and you
are talking trash about celebrities do
you do it to their face would you wait
till they're gone now I have what's
called manners is that what it's called
yes have you in the back when you're not
looking what the minute you leave
exactly I don't understand why unreality
shows people say you know if you have
something to say say it to my face I
would rather wait you left the room yeah
I think it's better it's called manners
and it's called being polite I can be
funnier when you are in your car right
so no I actually have like I call them
civilians I have like real people on my
show that and some of them haven't been
on television and they can speak freely
and not worry about getting banned from
the view right okay well like for
example you could you go up to Lisa
Rinna okay so I like Rinna she everybody
knows Lisa Rinna
she's from soap operas and she's got
like the crazy jacked-up lips and she's
a super nice girl she's very fit and I
see her and I know her and she's super
sweet but I will tell you I think it's
funny that she is now the spokesperson
for depends I didn't know thank you
exactly so I don't think anyone knew
that she tweeted a photo that I didn't
know that you did hi I've seen I've seen
the ads or like ads of her and Harry
Hamlin wearing diapers they love diapers
yeah oh my god are you not wearing
diapers they're so hot right now
everyone in Hollywood is very diverse so
if I had Lisa Rinna mine on this who
doesn't want to just sit here and poop
your pants off
it's a dream come true so how could I
have Lisa on my show how could I
interview her and say are you pooping
right now I how often do you poop how
has poop in your pants made your life
easier I can't be an appropriate host
like you are I just want to know about
her poop yeah I just dropped my pen is
that code for your dependent I'm good so
so you bet you if you sext time you see
here she'll be cool with it right I
don't know okay I'm just gonna grab
Charlie Sheen and say I'm with him and
push him I don't know and then madness
will break out always all right and then
I just have to ask you you tweeted this
weird photo that we're pretty much out
of time but I can just take a look at it
well there's Renee that's Rinna bikini
and I believe that she's like stuffed or
depends in the penis before you can you
she says I could rock it a bikini and
also depends yeah how am I going to talk
to her to her face I have to do it like
this and hope she doesn't watch it
frankly it's the two products that
you're getting for free tomorrow or
depends and Astroglide that's okay what
I meant was you tweeted this photo and
what is this what is happening here this
is you and your underwear you look
fantastic why why is there a window
washer there all right this is what's
called a window of opportunity here's
why I went I was in New York and I was
getting changed and sure enough the
window washer dude showed up and I was
with two gays shocked and two gay guys
and I just heard them go window washers
and I knew that men take my clothes off
and start jumping up and down so the
window washer doesn't seem to care good
care
and I was flirting and pointing and
waving and so we thought it was a good
Twitpic but no they didn't care one bit
all right well it was just a moment I
thought a moment I wasn't wearing two
pens I'm sorry
[Laughter]